president improperly holds classified
documents no not that one this one now
we've talked about the hot water that
former president Trump is in for holding
on to slash stealing question mark
classified documents and now President
Biden has made Headlines by potentially
doing something similar is this a big
deal or rather how big of a deal is this
our resident criminal law expert Spencer
takes a deep dive into Biden's hot docs
truly who Among Us does not have top
secret documents accumulating on her
nightstand like dirty water cups Joe
Biden is in hot or at least you know
like lukewarm water for having
classified documents in unsecured
locations and attorney general Merrick
Garland has appointed a special counsel
to look into the matter so what's the
deal with these classified documents and
how are they different from the Trump
situation at Mar-A-Lago and how are they
the same let's get into it so a little
background the timeline of Biden's
documents is as follows on November 2nd
2022 Joe Biden's personal attorneys find
classified records from Joe Biden's time
as vice president at Biden's office at
the Penn Biden Center in Washington DC
Think Tank sponsored by the University
of Pennsylvania according to Richard
Sauber special counsel to President
Biden the documents were discovered when
the president's personal attorneys were
packing files housed in a locked closet
to prepare to vacate office space at the
Penn Biden Center in D.C Biden's
attorneys informed the National Archives
and Records Administration or Nara of
their discovery that same day now as an
aside for those of you who feel like the
last three covetiers have stretched into
a bleak eternity and basically lost all
sense of time it's a flat circle Joe
Biden was Barack Obama's vice president
from 2009 to 2017. then Trump beat
Hillary in 2017 had really quite the
term in office and then Biden was doing
his own little thing over here and now
he's president and Trump isn't okay back
to the story the next day Nara refers
the issue to nara's own Inspector
General who in turn passes the matter
onto the Department of Justice on
November 4th the doj and the FBI
immediately began investigating the
matter meanwhile Biden's attorneys find
more classified documents at his garage
at his personal residence in Wilmington
Delaware according to Bob Bauer one of
Biden's attorneys they remain in close
contact with the doj and Nara throughout
this whole referral and investigation
process
now over the next month or so a handful
of additional documents are found in the
Wilmington House at that point attorney
general Merritt Garland reviewed the
special counsel regulations which say
that when matters are brought to the
attention of the Attorney General that
might warrant consideration of
appointment of a special counsel the
Attorney General may direct that an
initial investigation consisting of such
factual inquiry or legal research as the
Attorney General deems appropriate be
conducted in order to better inform the
decision
Garland followed the regulation and
directed U.S attorney John losh to make
the initial investigation
when losh told garland that further
investigation by a special counsel is
warranted Garland appointed Robert Herr
as special counsel for the matter
now her is a former U.S attorney for the
District of Maryland and worked as
principal counselor for Rod Rosenstein
then the deputy attorney general before
moving into private practice
Maryland Senators Chris Van Hollen and
Ben Cardin both Democrats as well as
Republican governor of Maryland Larry
Hogan have all vouched for her's
capability and work all told CBS news
reports that the total classified
documents found in Biden's possession
number around 20. some of which are top
secret the highest classification it's
unclear who visited Biden's home or
office while the documents were there
official residences like the White House
have thorough visitor logs that are
sometimes publicly available Dick Cheney
but that information isn't kept for
Biden's private residences or offices
the issue with Biden's documents is
different than Trump's at Mar-A-Lago for
many reasons but the biggest one is that
Biden and his lawyers have apparently
done nothing but cooperate fully with
Nara and the doj as opposed to say
repeatedly refusing to give up knowingly
prolonged documents to their rightful
owner thus forcing an FBI raid on your
home then say just as an example having
where you lied to said FBI about the
existence of more documents that that
would just be nuts right
right
I'm I'm sure that Joe Biden has already
Declassified everything with his mind so
problem solved joking aside having
classified documents at your home or
office is no laughing matter it could
have potentially serious implications
both criminally and politically so let's
dig in now what's really at issue here
unlike with Trump whose Mar-A-Lago
Shenanigans touched on many possible
crimes from false official statements to
obstruction of justice the Biden
situation at this point seems like it
really might only implicate one criminal
statute the Espionage Act the Espionage
of 1917 was passed as the name suggests
during World War One at the time
President Woodrow Wilson was deathly
afraid of foreign-born American citizens
seeking and I quote to bring the
authority and good name of our
government into contempt to destroy our
Industries wherever they thought it
effective for their vindictive purposes
to strike at them and to debase our
politics to the uses of foreign intrigue
the ACT has long been criticized for
being poorly written chilling a free
speech and a tool of intimidation but
it's on the books so here we go the
Espionage Act is codified under 18 USC
793 and contains a number of different
crimes involving information related to
National Defense there's one key word
that we're going to be using and it's
used throughout the literature about the
Espionage Act and which conveniently
never actually appears in the statute
and that's National Defense information
or ndi ndi means information relating to
National Defense that could be used to
the injury of the United States or to
the advantage of any foreign Nation ndi
can be found in many forms blueprints
code books photographs sketches whatever
you see everything you
you can see the big board now the courts
have cabined that definition a little
bit for prosecutions under the Espionage
Act
to prosecute someone for say
transferring or mishandling ndi the ndi
has to be closely held now that's not in
the statute it's a court-created rule to
get around First Amendment concerns and
some other challenges basically closely
held means not publicly available
obviously if the dod issues a press
release talking about how fifth Fleet is
steaming towards Bahrain it's no longer
closely held information relating to the
National Defense so it's not ndi but
it's actually more than that it doesn't
take a press release to make something
no longer ndi ndi is information that
has not been made public and is not
available to the public for example the
gym schedule on a military base
that may not be available to the public
in the sense that it's like on a website
but there's no prohibition on service
members on that base communicating the
schedule to their friends or Partners or
spouses and when you look at it that way
it's sometimes helpful to identify ndi
as something that is actively withheld
from the public and that is how we get
to classification the Espionage of 1917
doesn't talk about classification it
doesn't distinguish between secret or
top secret or no foreign or five eyes or
whatever
instead for the purposes of prosecution
under the Espionage Act classification
is circumstantial evidence that a
document is closely held in other words
you classify ndi and classification
markings indicate that it's ndi but to
be clear you don't need classification
markings for ndi it's just really useful
before we head into the actual criminal
components of the Espionage Act it's
worth saying this the Penn Biden Center
and Joe Biden's residence are not lawful
places to store ndi the possession of
ndi at those locations is generally not
authorized so is there a crime the
Espionage Act 18 USC section 793
contains a bunch of different crimes now
no one is claiming that Biden flew over
a submarine base snapping photos with
the intent of passing those photos to
say Peru so let's start with subsection
D when you lawfully have possession of
ndi it's a crime to do one of two things
first willfully give it to someone who's
not entitled to receive it and second
willfully retain it and then fail to
deliver it to a government employee upon
demand let's call this the Spy provision
I think it'll make sense you're working
in a government office you lawfully have
access to some top secret information
and you pass it off to your Peruvian
Handler you just violated subsection D
or maybe you walk out of the office with
a thumb drive full of top secret
material that you're you know otherwise
allowed to have and your supervisor
comes running out after you yelling that
she knows what's on the hard drive and
that you need to give it to her right
now well if you respond by running off
your beat up Geo Metro that you can
barely afford on your government salary
you have also violated subsection D and
that takes us to subsection e because
with subsection e the starting point is
having unauthorized possession of ndi if
you have unauthorized possession of ndi
it is a crime to willfully give it to
someone who's not entitled to receive it
or willfully retain it and fail to
deliver it to a government employee
entitled to receive it so obviously that
first part is basically the same as
subsection D it's just that you aren't
entitled to possess the ndi in the first
place so if you pick up a folder marked
top secret from the floor of the DC
Subway you can't just sell it to the
Fijian Embassy in fact it's worth noting
that for subsection e there is no
requirement like with subsection D that
there be some demand from a government
employee to return it if you have
unauthorized possession of ndi and you
fail to deliver it to a government
employee entitled to receive it
immediately
you just committed a crime
so when you find that folder marked top
secret on the floor of the DC Subway you
better just walk that thing over to the
closest FBI office and no Pixies
you'll be fine the person who dropped it
they're going to get fired
at best so let's bring this back to
Biden subsection D presumes lawful
possession of ndi while subsection e
presumes unauthorized possession of ndi
but both statutes rely on willful
conduct you're either willfully giving
ndi to someone or willfully retaining it
and not returning it the key word here
is willfully and the courts have held
that in this context willfully means
having designed to mislead or deceive
another that is not prompted by an
honest mistake as to one's duties but
prompted by some personal or underhanded
motive and at this stage with the
limited information that we have it
would be really hard to attach such a
motive to Biden
what we do know is that as lawyers
contacted Nara in November to report
that they had found ndi at the Penn
Biden Center and then made additional
reports for ndi founded Biden's home in
Delaware
regardless of whether we look at this as
unlawful transfer of ndi or as unlawful
retention of ndi it would seem that the
government would have a hard time
proving willfulness given the
information we have there's another
issue what makes possession lawful
versus unauthorized
in other words does a former vice
president fall under subsection D or
subsection e oddly enough that might
depend on a clock specifically the
National Institute of Science and
Technology's nist F1 cesium Fountain
atomic clock that clock sets the US's
official time and is so precise that it
won't gain or lose a second in 100
million years so why the hell are we
talking about an atomic clock well
because the official transfer of power
between the Obama Administration where
Biden was vice president and the Trump
Administration where Biden was just a
cool dude washing his Camaro and a tank
top and denim cutoffs happened at
exactly 12 o'clock P.M Eastern Standard
Time on January 20th 2017. at exactly
that moment when the cesium-133 atom
vibrated just so Vice President Biden
went from a top level classification
authority to well just a dude with a car
a hose and some soap now as far as
subsections D and ego it kind of doesn't
really matter
let's say the ndi materials were
transferred to the Penn Biden Center or
Biden's residence before Biden legally
left office then maybe he falls under
subsection D having had lawful
possession of the ndi materials but the
ultimate question will be whether the
transfer or retention was willful
regardless of whether it's under
subsection D or E and that standard
requires more than an honest mistake it
requires a personal or underhanded
motive which with the limited evidence
we have just doesn't really seem to
exist maybe he was biting his time until
a National Ice Cream shortage to jump
ship so if subsections D and E are kinda
off the table
what's left well there's one more
subsection of the Espionage Act worth
looking at instead of the starting point
of lawful possession for subsection D or
unauthorized possession for subsection e
subsection F's starting point is this
being entrusted with or having lawful
possession or control of ndi now that's
a little bigger than just lawful
possession and the meaning of being
entrusted with hasn't really been
explored much by the courts let's just
assume for the sake of argument that
atomic clock notwithstanding Biden was
entrusted with or had lawful possession
or control of the ndi at issue again
that's just an assumption well once you
assume that it's a crime to do one of
two things first if you through gross
negligence permit the ndi to be removed
from its proper place of custody or
delivered to anyone in violation of the
trust or be lost stolen abstracted or
destroyed that's a crime
second if you're a government employee
and have knowledge that the ndi has been
illegally removed from its proper place
of custody or delivered to anyone in
violation of its trust or lost or stolen
abstracted or destroyed and you fail to
make a prompt report of it to your
Superior officer that's also a crime
let's start with that second part the
government employee one the text of that
part of subsection F requires that a
person make a prompt report to a
superior officer if you believe Richard
Sauber the special counsel to President
Biden they found the documents at the
Penn Biden Center in a Closet during a
move of office space on November 2nd
2022 at that time Biden was President so
he doesn't really have a superior
officer so I mean arguably this part of
subsection F doesn't really apply but
even if it does apply they did make a
report of it to Nara immediately so it
seems to comply with that second part of
subsection f as for the first part of
subsection F the question is really
whether Biden through gross negligence
permitted the ndi to be removed from its
proper place of custody or to be lost
stolen abstracted or destroyed that last
thing lost stolen abstracted or
destroyed I mean that probably doesn't
apply and that's kind of generous
because who knows what abstracted means
maybe it's like when you turn ndi into a
performance art piece or something
so what remains did Biden through gross
negligence permit the ndi to be removed
from its proper place of custody I mean
that sure sounds good if you want Biden
to be guilty of a crime under the
Espionage Act I mean if he has ndi at
his house how 'd that not be grossly
negligent well
bad news gross negligence is actually a
pretty high standard negligence itself
is basically a failure to Accord with a
standard of care you're in a particular
situation you're supposed to be careful
in a certain way and if you're not
careful in that way then it's negligent
gross negligence is an extension of that
it doesn't have one single uniform
definition but you could probably sum it
up as a wanton or Reckless disregard for
a standard of care here's an example
you're a paramedic on duty and instead
of listening to your radio you're
smoking and joking with your buddies and
you miss a radio call and someone's hurt
that could be negligent there's a
standard of care to listen to the radio
on duty and you're not meeting that
standard now imagine the same situation
but you the paramedic decide to turn the
radio off entirely so it doesn't
interfere with your little personal time
that could be gross negligence because
you're not just failing to meet the
standard you're actively going against
that standard knowing what the
consequences could be given what we know
does Biden meet that standard of gross
negligence when it comes to ndi
I mean probably not based on what we
know so far we don't know much I mean
who knows what dark Brandon's up to the
information we do have mostly has to do
with the discovery timeline of the ndi
materials not how the materials got to
the Penn Biden Center or Biden's
residence in Delaware in the first place
was it movers was it Biden's direct
subordinates was it Biden himself
grabbing documents from the Resolute
desk on the last day like a high school
wrestler at the last call at the buffet
I mean we just don't know but the
standard for gross negligence is so high
that it would require some incredibly
compelling evidence to show that Biden
wantonly disregarded the standard of
care with respect to how ndi materials
should be handled that evidence hasn't
been released yet that's for sure now
let's let's step back for a second we
recently discussed the reasons why
Merrick Garland appointed a special
counsel over the Trump matters the same
rationale applies for Biden's special
counsel when there is an apparent
conflict of interest or special
Circumstance the regulations require
that the Attorney General appoint a
special counsel 28 CFR 600.1 States the
Attorney General will appoint a special
counsel when he or she determines that
criminal investigation of a person or
matter is warranted provided the
following conditions are met
investigation or prosecution of that
person or matter by the Department of
Justice would present a conflict of
interest for the department or other
extraordinary circumstances
and that under the circumstances it
would be in the public interest to
appoint an outside special counsel to
assume responsibility for the matter
although Garland didn't say that it
would be a conflict of interest for him
to criminally investigate his boss that
is a textbook conflict of interest
instead Garland invoked the first
condition that there were extraordinary
circumstances now I suppose that we
could quibble with the meaning of
extraordinary circumstances
but let's be real we live in a world
where two senior citizens who have been
presidents both had classified documents
in their private residences one of them
was subject to a search by the FBI and
both are running for president again in
2024. that's extraordinary and it is in
the public interest to have impartial
investigations into both situations
it would not have been right for Garland
to personally investigate and make
decisions about criminally Prosecuting
Biden by appointing her Biden and Trump
are being treated equally well
treated kind of equally because when
we're talking about possible criminal
consequences for Biden unlikely as they
are with the facts that we have we have
to keep in mind that he is right now and
you may not know this the president of
the United States and Trump is not
and it is long-standing doj policy that
a sitting president cannot be federally
prosecuted so even if and I really
stress that if Biden Were Somehow
criminally culpable Federal prosecution
couldn't happen until he's out of office
Trump meanwhile could be prosecuted
right now but because Biden is the
sitting president there's something that
could happen to him now that can't
happen to Trump
impeachment of course to be fair Trump
was impeached twice but honestly it
seems like a lifetime ago House
Republicans are already gearing up for
their own investigation and it's not
like House Republicans weren't already
itching to impeach if it wasn't this it
would have been something out of the
hunter Biden extended Universe proving
that Biden was grossly negligent to a
jury would be vastly different than
proving the same thing to a majority
Republican house so that's where we are
the differences between the Biden and
Trump situations are substantial and
those differences really impact any
theoretical criminal liability
but we don't have all the facts right
now and chances are good that the House
Republicans are going to drive towards
impeachment regardless of what special
counsel Herr discovers
at this point
it's a waiting game
yeah and now we have even more news just
days after Garland appointed Robert her
a special counsel the FBI searched
Biden's Wilmington home for more
classified material and they found it
the search took 13 hours and the justice
department removed quote six items
consisting of documents with
classification markings and surrounding
materials some of which were from the
president's service in the Senate and
some of which were from his tenure as
vice president and the FBI also removed
some personally handwritten notes from
Biden's vice presidential years prior
documents were found in Biden's garage
but investigators have not revealed
where the six items were located the
justice department confirmed that Biden
invited the FBI to search for documents
there was no search warrant and her did
not request access to the house this was
the fourth batch of Records found in
Biden's possession since November we
also learned a little more about why
Biden's lawyers did not immediately
search The Garage earlier they thought
all the file boxes had gone to the Penn
Biden Center because that was the
impression they got from the officials
working in the presidential transition
in 2017. but these new facts make the
bike in case look a lot like the case of
former Attorney General Alberto Gonzalez
who worked for George W bush in 2008 An
Inspector General found that Gonzalez
had improperly stored classified
documents at his home and work in 2004
when Gonzalez was the White House
counsel he made notes about a classified
NSA briefing and kept draft opinions
about a detainee interrogation program
and kept other memoranda describing
legal and operational aspects of the two
classified programs and when someone
writes notes about classified documents
it renders the notes classified as well
and like Biden Gonzalez took his notes
to his house some of the notes contained
top secret SCI information about the NSA
codeword surveillance programs and
Gonzalez wrote the top secret code name
of the program on an outer envelope he
stored the notes in a briefcase and
after Gonzalez was appointed as attorney
general he took the notes from his
private residence to his office at Maine
Justice where he failed to store them in
a skiff the IG discovered 17 more
classified documents marked top secret
SCI in Gonzalez's office safe which was
not an approved location to store them
and several employees without the
necessary security clearances had access
to them Gonzalez did not self-report the
missing documents he claimed to be
unaware of their classified status but
there was some evidence that he did in
fact know how sensitive they were he
wrapped the notes in two envelopes and
wrote AG Eyes Only top secret on the
outer envelope the Inspector General
found that Gonzalez mishandled
classified materials nonetheless the
Department of Justice declined to
prosecute Gonzales they analyzed his
handling of the notes under the gross
negligence provision in 18 USC's 793 and
although prosecutors could probably show
that gonzalo's documents were removed
from their proper place of custody as
Spencer explained they would have a hard
time proving the required constituted
gross negligence approving criminal
recklessness is a really high bar
Gonzalez claimed to be unaware that the
documents were classified although his
notes suggested otherwise well Biden
said he didn't know a locked garage
wasn't a proper place for the documents
and Common Sense would seem to suggest
otherwise in that case although you
could include that both of these guys
should have known better their claims
still present a problem for prosecutors
who need to prove intent and the gazelle
all his declinations suggests the doj
will not prosecute Biden in this case as
well based on what we know so far
Gonzalez cooperated with the ig's
investigation by turning over documents
and allowing the searches Biden like
Gonzalez has not attempted to obstruct
their return Dick Durbin said that when
that information is found it diminishes
the stature of any person who is in
possession of it because it's not
supposed to happen whether it was the
fault of a staffer or an attorney it
makes no difference the elected official
bars ultimate responsibility and
ultimately National Security Law expert
Brad Moss is probably right here when he
says Biden's sloppiness with how he
handled classified document storage over
the years is a problem of his own making
the FBI investigation into it is fully
warranted whether he is vulnerable to
criminal liability remains to be seen so
we'll see what kind of penalties are
handed down to Biden or his staff for
leaving classified documents at Biden's
Delaware home
[Music]
and breaking news classified documents
have been discovered at former vice
president Mike Pence's Indiana home
because apparently everyone has
classified documents at their house now
just one week after Garland appointed
Richard Herr as special counsel in the
Biden case Pence asked an attorney to
review four boxes stored in his house
and lo and behold there were about 12
documents with classified markings the
FBI and the Justice Department's
National Security division have launched
an investigation now Pence's lawyer
wrote a letter to Nara explaining the
situation and stating where and when he
would return the documents to Nara he
also promised that his client would
fully cooperate with the US government
now Pence had previously said he didn't
have any classified documents in his
possession but it wouldn't be surprising
given the recent news that Pence decided
to search just in case and it's fair to
assume that all of America's prior
leaders are probably undertaking a
similar search we're looking at you
Jimmy Carter now if Garland follows
recent president then is likely he will
appoint an independent Council for Pence
as well it's not unusual for Nara to ask
ex-presidents to return documents and
given the volume of documents created
during a presidential Administration
It's Not Unusual for some straight
documents to be found in storage but the
number of classified document scandals
demonstrates that people are not
following procedure and also hints at
the over classification documents which
is its own separate issue but the way
that Biden and Pence handled this
discovery highlights how much Trump
deviated from the norm here he allegedly
refused to give documents back and
continues to insist that he has a right
to keep them so we'll see if any
criminal sanctions are handed down to
Biden or Pence for storing classified
documents in their home because and I
can't believe I have to say this homes
are not for storing classified documents
they are for making delicious
home-cooked meals which you can get with
today's sponsor hellofresh they're so
delicious that they feel like they
should be illegal because hellofresh is
a great way to eat delicious fresh food
while still being healthy it's a great
way to start the new year right in fact
hellofresh has a whole variety of
calorie smart carb smart pescetarian and
veggie options and you can customize it
how however you like hellofresh delivers
fresh quality produce from the farm to
your door in less than a week so you can
enjoy favorites like the Falafel
Powerball seared steak and potatoes with
Renee sauce or Southwest pork and bean
burritos now I'm a do-it-yourself person
and I have to say I was initially
skeptical about hellofresh I'm a pretty
good cook so I didn't really think that
I needed the help but I actually loved
it even for an experienced cook
hellofresh delivers new ingredients and
recipes that I'd never try on my own
hellofresh generally keeps everyone's
favorite meals and then rotates new ones
in all the time in fact I usually
increase the size of my hellofresh
servings so I can enjoy the leftovers
for lunch which saves me even more time
and of course everything was delivered
straight to my door so I didn't have to
do any shopping the produce actually
gets you faster than a grocery store so
it arrives at Peak freshness and flavor
and it's also super easy to save time
because hellofresh cuts out the meal
planning and prep and recipes only take
20 to 30 minutes to cook literally less
time to cook than it would have normally
taken to do the shopping itself it's
also incredibly sustainable because the
packaging is almost entirely made from
recyclable or already recycled content
and hellofresh's carbon footprint is
actually 25 lower than that of meals
made from store bought groceries and 72
percent cheaper than dining at a
restaurant so if you would like to try
hellofresh you can go to hellofresh.com
and use the code legal eagle21 for up to
21 free meals yes you can actually get
21 free meals and that includes free
shipping or you can just click on the
link that's on screen right now or down
in the description so again for up to 21
free meals go to hellofresh.com and use
the code legaleagle21 or just click on
the link below plus click on that link
really helps out this Channel and after
that click on this playlist over here
for more legal eagle or I'll see you in
court